[Music]
congrats on the new album you know the
thing i noticed while listening to it
was it covers so many emotions did you
set out to write an album that really
did cover it all or is that just kind of
what flowed out i mean listen man i
don't know about you but like
it happens over the course of a day you
know i'm not i'm not a stuffed animal
man i like anyone i get i get sad i
i do all kinds of things we have a
family show sorry about
that one
the album was pushed back and i'm sure
that's due to
the global health crisis that we were
all in did that give you a bit of
inspiration to write new tracks in a
creative sense absolutely i mean um i
don't think anything could be more
inspiring than a worldwide um experience
you know i thought we were done with
this record
beforehand so yeah i think this record
is so much better
with the time i had and like there's
like at least five songs that i can
think of right now that are on there uh
that probably wouldn't have been on
there without this time
[Music]
listen i was thinking who i would love
to see you collab with earlier today
when i was listening to some of the
music and in my mind i would personally
love i don't know if you would ever do
it but i would be so
into a miley cyrus collab oh hell yeah
well you know i called out with her
sister noah all the time who's awesome
she's just the coolest person ever as is
miley from uh what i hear i love miley's
boys
i was a huge fan of miley's plastic
hearts album which was fantastic just in
my brain the two of you together
i'm i'm so game for that another thing i
love about you is you have this amazing
sense of style like everything in my
life
i try to just try to please myself
you know i'm always like dressed like
i'll never be home again it's like the
movie of my life where it's just like oh
my god there's this tragedy happening
run for your life and i'm like i look
like fantastic i'm ready for the movie
to roll with this exact outfit for the
rest of the movie and i'm not gonna be
like
i left the house with the wrong shoes of
trying to be cool trying to feel cool
for myself you're going to be hitting
the road in january which is super
exciting i'm sure you're really excited
to get back out there and perform what
would you say is more draining on the
body
would it be the touring or the actual
performance every night i don't think
the performance is that draining but the
touring i mean you know you mean the
other
22 and a half hours of the day
that was draining for sure but stage is
my favorite
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos